two
run and you're live thank you chairman
good evening and welcome to this
strategy and resources committee meeting
on thursday the 19th november 2020
my name is councillor richard siddall
and i am the chairman of the committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came
into effect on the 4th of april in
response to the covid 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting
to ensure your microphone remains muted
and your video feed
off when not addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any
unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded and by being
present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to be recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to
to leave the meeting the chat function
should not be used
for questions or any other purposes
this is extremely important tonight as
we have
an external representative attending the
meeting
who can read the chat function
please do not use the raise hand
function as this is not available on all
members devices
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page or a
paragraph number
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function
to signify that you need to leave the
meeting
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting
to introduce themselves starting with mr
leslie
good evening chris leslie director of
resources
thank you chris uh mr porches
good evening lance porteous lead finance
specialist
uh miss bird good evening
chairman good evening members tara bird
community services officer for the
evening thank you
thank you lance and thank you tara are
there any other officers present
good evening chair steven butcher
commercial manager
good evening stephen thank you evening
chair
richard thomas director of service
delivery thank you richard
community chair matt wilson countryside
and case manager
good evening thank you and good evening
paul dodson director of strategy
performance and governance
thank you very much paul tara please can
you now carry out a roll call of members
to confirm who is in attendance
thank you thank you chairman members if
you could just indicate when i call your
name if you're here please
i'm starting with council mrs channer
please
um hold on i'm just so we have to do
this let you see me yes here i am
thank you i'm present tara good evening
members everyone else
thank you thank you councillor durham
uh good evening miss bird good evening
chairman good evening members i'm
present thank you
good evening councillor edwards
good evening uh present good evening
thank you
councillor helm
president tara thank you very much
council
dear again evening tomorrow good evening
all members of the community officers
and everybody on the call on present
tara
thank you very much and councillors
littleton councillor schemes
good evening everybody good evening
thank you councillor stamp
yeah good evening chairman good evening
members good evening officers
present councillor swain
yes president tara thank you very much
councillor mrs thompson
good evening tara good evening everyone
yes i'm present thank you
thank you and chairman we understand
council miss white is on her way but is
running a bit late
um members could i ask any members in
attendance please if they could advise
they're in here please thank you
good evening uh good evening members
and uh staff councillor mark herr
chairman of the council
thank you good evening and welcome
chrissy morris is here morris
and also ann hole thank you council huh
good evening chair good evening members
uh councillor passenger
in attendance thank you council
messenger
chairman that concludes the roll call
for this evening's meeting thank you
okay thank you miss bird uh item number
two on the agenda
is apologies for absence and we've heard
that
uh councillor white will be running late
and hopefully turn up at some particular
point and then no other apologies
so as a number three is the minutes of
the 17th of september 2020.
it's recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 17th of
september 2020 found on pages five to
ten
are approved as a true and accurate
record
by so move if you wish to second that
motion
please turn on your video and mute and
mute even
your microphone and state your name now
a second thank you this way
if any member wishes to raise any
matters of accuracy please use the chat
function to indicate
and i will invite you to speak
tara has anybody asked to speak at all
and no chairman there's no indication of
anyone wishing to speak on this item
thank you okay so can i
take uh the uh minutes uh
in terms of a matter of a cent the
council's degree
agreement
thank you members so item number four is
declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disposable pecuniary interest
other peculiar interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regards to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are
required to close
any such interests as soon as they
become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare
please use the chat function now to
indicate and i will invite you to
speak i see the first person is
counselor channel
thank you chairman um i will be
declaring
um non-pecuniary interest as a member of
essex county council
and certainly um i've seen their
reference to them in
i think it was a gender item six and
seven but anywhere else on the agenda
that it might pertain to them
and also chairman um regarding when we
get to
items 13 14 and 15 which will be the
precursor to going well they are going
to be including the precursor going into
private session
i will be removing myself from the
chamber for the private and confidential
matter
um and i don't know if i can say this in
public
but because um an organization mentioned
within the document i
am a member of that body which i'm
appointed to through
um a body via essex county council so
i feel bearing in mind every time it has
arisen this matter pertaining to the
item
in that private and confidential i have
never been involved
in a discussion at malden district
council so i will vacate the chamber
chairman
and i didn't want to identify the body
i'm a member of because i think it might
give the game away what the item might
be
okay so i'm not being secretive it's
just
i understand be careful thank you very
much
uh councillor yes i'm a member of the
west key houseboat association which
holds
a lease with morgan district council uh
it's there for a pecuniary
interest uh but uh and i'm not actually
sure
if it comes up specifically in this i
didn't find it but uh
i will maintain my awareness and if i
have to i'll withdraw
should such things come up okay thank
you council skeets
councillor lagan
yeah thank you chair i'll declare a
non-pecuniary interest in the gender
item number nine
fees and charges policy uh as i've had
some
conversations with some of those persons
potentially affected by the policies
and also agenda item number 12 please
check
because i've had again some
non-procurement conversations
with members of that organization thank
you council logan
and councillor durham
thank you chairman uh pretty much the
same uh declaration of non-pecuniary
interest as
councillor chana but perhaps a bit
briefer um because of course
ethics county council um as well as
morgan district councils
are beneficiaries of both business rate
and council tax income thank you okay
thank you council durham
tara is there anybody else who has uh
indicated a wish to speak
and no chairman that is everybody thank
you thank you very much uh item number
five
is public participation i can advise
that we have not received
any submissions from the members of the
public to speak
so we move on to item number six which
is budgetary control
april to september 2020
we move to agenda item 6 budgetary
control found on pages 11-24
member please note the addendum
circulated prior to the meeting
in respect to this item of business
founded found on pages three to four
of the addendum pack members a reminder
that if you wish to speak on this item
please make this known by using the chat
function when this within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points
clear and succinct i would now ask mr
leslie
to please present the report
thank you chairman members may notice
the presentation of the budgetary
control report
is perhaps slightly different to the
past the reason
is that we're looking at a more
risk-based approach and also
an approach that we hope is more
transparent and provides a bit more
clarity
around the budget i'll talk through the
uh budget uh in the report
referring to the tables one at a time so
from page 11
table one this provides a high level
overview
of the budget now you can see that the
expenditure there is split
roughly half and half between employee
costs
and non-employee costs
net service expenditure there at the
bottom
that's the amount that's funded mainly
from
local taxation council tax business
rates
and also some other items such as
general government grants the forecast
variance tab at the moment caused by the
impact of covid
you can see the income professionals
are actually the largest here although a
sizeable amount in the
non-employee costs as well
if we move on to the next page to table
two
this provides the top expenditure areas
these eight items cover nearly three
quarters of the non-employee
expenditure there you can see the
refusing recycling
at the top by far the largest and a
further breakdown of that is available
in the appendices when taking the
salaries expenditure and these eight
items of expenditure
that's 87 of the council's expenditure
so
hopefully very clearly you can get an
understanding
of the size of the council's budgets and
how
it's broken down just by reference to
those
items uh the employees
costs are broken down a bit further in
the appendices
as i said this is uh something that's a
bit of a
work in progress and i hope to be able
to provide some more information
around that as we go forward and start
to improve the reporting process
i'll refer on now to the next page table
three you can again see the top income
areas this time
13 areas making up um
82 of the income
worth pointing out that car parking
income is up there as well
and it's obviously been hit by the
pandemic as well as the leisure center
management fee income
so with these items um impacting i'm
referred to table five now
you can see that actually the
expenditure has been offset largely by
the government grants that we've had
through from covit the income
compensation scheme particularly
and also the general covered grants the
government has provided
so a budget total budget variant shown
there in
table five uh worth noting that is
substantially less than that originally
reported at the start
because of the grants that have come
through from central groundwork that
weren't expected at the time
and finally just to go on to table six
bit further on the report
uh you can see the impact on the general
fund balance
there projected still staying well above
the 2.6
million minimum level
thank you jim
thank you mr leslie the recommendation
set out in the report is as follows that
the members
note the contents of the report if any
members wish
to second that motion please turn on
your video unmute your microphone
and state your name now uh counselor
wendy stamp i'd like to second the
motion please
chair thank you councillor stamp
i will now invite members to make any
comments on the report
tara who has indicated that they wish to
speak
uh thank you chairman i just counsel mrs
channel at the moment thank you
okay counselor china um thank you
chairman
just just a query really because i noted
it um i noticed it is a report for
noting
and um we did have uh the issue of
whereby
reports for noting wouldn't go to
committee but would be noted on the
agenda as i was led to understand at the
bottom
i'm just one it might because the
importance of this but
that was my understanding just about
process so
as i say it is a report for for noting
um
that was my inquiry inquiry religion
okay
the reason why it has been brought to
committee is because of its importance
and to ensure that members are kept
informed about the
uh the breakdown and the finances of the
council so therefore
as we move forward in in terms of
setting the budgets that we are keeping
members
informed and also ensuring that they're
able to ask any questions
so due to the importance that's why it's
been brought to this committee
thank you councillor dharam
thank you very much chairman um
yeah it's obviously a huge concern that
we're you know likely to be one and a
half million pounds shy on our
um on our uh income
um a 4.5.4
there's an estimate of a reduction of
about 200
000 pounds on the the tax take um
i've just come off another meeting at
essex where this subject has come up
and i'm just wondering you know from
what i've heard
uh the um the reduction in tax takes
potentially quite a lot more than
anybody was anticipating i'm just
wondering when that figure was put in
um you know whether that should be uh
adjusted in the light
of more information thank you chairman
uh mr leslie would you like to answer
that question
yes uh yes because we reflected as more
information comes to life the current
figures were based on
the collection rates at the time and
that's what's been used to calculate so
they were
based on the most up-to-date figures at
the time but of course will be updated
as we go forward okay thank you mr
leslie
are there any other members who would
like to speak on this item
uh chairman council logins indicated you
wish to speak okay
uh councillor logan sorry i missed you
thank you
that's okay um there's no problems there
at all um
just a couple of quick questions if i
may uh for mr leslie
um chris it's a really excellent report
um
understandable for those of us that are
not uh gifted in the world of financial
management so
i just want to say thank you very much
indeed for that and a question as well
on the 2.6 million uh minimum for the
general fund level
for for my own awareness is that a level
that's set by government or is that a
level that's set by
us as an authority
yeah so that's a level which is set
council uh the start of the year section
151 officer
uh provides a minimum level of
recommended reserves
for that and that happens in during the
budget setting um
time so it's down to the council and
each uh council will obviously have
their own risks
associated with that lovely thank you
thank you very much indeed thank you
any other questions council logan no
okay
uh no that's it thank you chair thank
you very much
obviously the the yeah without covid the
council uh finances uh are stretched
currently and kobe does put that extra
pressure on to the
finances and i'd like to thank uh mr
leslie for producing such a detailed and
understandable report
which helps us as members understand the
situation that the council is facing
over the coming years we will have to
address how we how we deal with some of
these matters
and hopefully if we get some more
government grants in the next few months
that will assist us in
our financial situation currently so
uh i would now like to uh
move the item for a vote can i take this
via a cent or would you like
um a recorded vote on this
ascent german it's fine
recommendations just for noting yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah i'm happy to go with
a scent
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you chairman happy to know that's
thompson
happy to agree yeah yeah noted yeah okay
thank you very much members
so we now move on to agenda item seven
which is the medium term
financial strategy for 21 22 to 22
23 24 found i'm saying lots of numbers
found on pages 25 to 132
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item
please make this known by using the chat
function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr leslie please can you present the
report
thank you i've just made some brief
references um
to the report this is part of our
commitment
to keep bringing forward updated
medium-term financial strategies given
the uncertainty
around uh covid at the moment and since
the report was written we have entered
lockdown so it just shows you how
quickly things
change i'll just refer on page 26 to
uh table one there really which does lay
out
uh some of the cost pressures that are
facing
the council at the moment in future
years
[Music]
you can see from there that it's the
inflationary pressures that do continue
going forward and also from the funding
side you can see that there's
flat lines there largely due to
reductions in government funding
around the new homes bonus
um if i refer to the below chart
chart one there i think it gives a bit
of a graphical representation
of the issues ahead as the fund in
flatlines
and the inflationary pressures that
staff and
non-staffing inflationary pressures
continue
like to give a reference there in
section six on page 27
just to highlight the fact that uh the
uncertainties around covered
and we have done some work on looking at
some possible scenarios
we hope these are more pessimistic
scenarios
than anything else um but we look to try
and quantify
some of the uncertainties around covert
at the moment and of course what we
don't know
uh in this report is the funding that
may
assist with some of these pressures and
as well
so in terms of the next page from table
five
which will spit out those uh pressures
which are due to business as usual
almost those inflationary pressures
that continue and also those coveted
pressures you can see that there's a
balance
without the copic pressures and then the
balance obviously including
the covered pressures so of course it's
quite significant pressures as you'd
expect
but it's very uncertain at the moment we
don't know what government funding is
coming forward for that and just lastly
i would like to highlight
um the growth items that have been put
forward
as well ahead that's a precursor to the
budget setting
and so you give these members as much
time as possible
to engage within those just like to
highlight that particular one
thank you
thank you mr leslie uh
so i would now like to put forward the
recommendation that the updated medium
term financial strategy for
2122 to 2324 as at the 19th of november
that appendix won't be noted if any
member
wishes to second that motion please turn
on your video now
and mute your microphone and state your
name
councillor wendy stan pass second that
chairman please
thank you councillor stamp has anybody
uh invite indicated that they wish to
speak tara
no chairman nobody has okay
okay fair enough uh so
i i i will speak on this myself then uh
and one of the things that yeah we need
to look at
is in terms of uh appendix two
is those are proposals that have been
put forward by the officers of the
council
so if there are any items on there that
uh we have a query or question about
then this is your opportunity to to
raise that now and also in terms of the
the expenditure uh that is being put
forward
uh by the officers so again if there is
any recommendations
that members would like to put to the
offices uh
they would are quite happy yeah welcome
to hear those things
and just had
i can't see it because it's councillor
swain chairman
okay councillor sway
yes can i chairman i go back to
the table four at the magic
classification for mr nesley
um about the assumed impact covered in
future years
um as i understand the table there are
significant um what should we say
shortfalls
um from the leisure center management
fee stretching into 2324
um but for promenade park activities
this is the zeros presumably implies we
would be
back to normal levels of events and
income
have i understood that correctly
thank yes miss leslie nice and succinct
does that answer your question
christopher counts this way is that you
happy with that
um well yes i suppose so as i was
thinking does it
does it um it involves the same
assumptions about
utilization in other words it's assuming
that leisure center activity is
definitely not back to
past levels in any of those years
yeah that yeah that's correct i mean it
depends uh
just as expanding i think on the ledger
center one uh the other one
in terms of the zeros quite right the
activity back to zero and everything
continues
to expand the leisure center um one then
it's very much an unknown
how this will go forward we've got a
vaccine in process but we just don't
know
how demand and opening of leisure
centers may be impacted and activities
so it's very much
a bit of a guesswork behind
what could happen around activity yes
it's probably fairly pessimistic
assumptions do you think
yeah very possibly i certainly hope they
are yes
thank you okay thank you mr leslie
uh so we now come to um
just hold on i'm trying to go with the
two things here it's quite difficult um
the paperwork and everything so i'm
really going to appendix
2 on page 67 when it can come up on my
screen as well
and that is appendix 2 isn't it i'm
doing it from memory now
um yes it is so it's appendix two and
really i'll go back to backtracking i
made to
page 66. um can you all hear me because
it seems like i'm yeah
all right okay lovely i'm getting this
issue again with my i might have to take
them off again
um regarding the um digital um
scheme i i would like to just i think
that's very good and i can see why we do
need that
and certainly i think with covid and
bearing in mind hopefully
the vaccinations might um come in and do
perhaps what they do so we get back to
some minimality but if we don't then
having the digital
um sort of um digitalization that
officers are planning and freeing up the
space will be good
um but i think that's more on page 65
and then it goes on to 66.
could i just ask on page 66 it says here
about service delivery and safeguarding
admin
and it says here to allow scafeguarding
leads to have administration rights
in fresh service i'd perhaps just like
to
have a clearer understanding
of what that means exactly because as
soon as i see about safeguarding
and people having access to stuff um
i i just like an expansion on that
and then chairman do you want the next
question because it goes on to the next
page to do the surface delivery or would
you like me to stop there
i think we'll like take that question
first of all and uh mr holmes
says he can provide the answer for us
thank you chairman uh yes through you um
this is actually for the team
internal team of the council who manage
our safeguarding cases
they use a platform an i.t platform to
operate the service and share records
unfortunately they don't all have the
licenses to be able to do that
so it's a completely contained internal
service
for operational use so all of the data
sharing is obviously
completely appropriate because it is
within the council itself
thank you very much do you want me to
announce the next question chairman
please
counselor thank you um this is on page
67
service delivery staffing
now maybe this is me looking at
something the wrong way but rebs and
ben's
specialist it's the first item really
and i'm looking at the growth for 2122.
now the way that's written it's it's
going on about
10 pounds or i don't think you mean 10
pounds i think are you meaning 10
000 because then you mentioned you meant
38k
so i just thought if we're talking 38k
and then 100k in the end box
perhaps that might be helpful bearing in
mind members of the public probably read
this
um to sort of keep the uniform chairman
that's where i was coming from because
when a member of the public might read
that with a 10 pound if process
improvement
yeah it is absolutely so i've just been
a bit pedantic i guess but actually
i was meaning that because um i i
thought i think i know what you meant
but i just think it's helpful that
we make sure it does say ten thousand or
it's clear that it is ten thousand
can we just clarify that it's not ten
pounds and it is ten thousand
yes apologies for that it's uh not 10
pounds it's 10 pounds
yes yes sorry chairman but i just
because when i first read it i mean
it confused me a bit i guessed i knew
but i thought i would make sure
my thinking was correct thank you
chairman thank you very much council
tenner
uh i have a question on uh
oh councillor stamp you i i will give
way to you
uh thank you chairman mine just a query
really
looking at the same as council channel
page 67
service delivery staffing the project
manager role
um can anybody um give me some more
information on that
when will it start who will they
directly report to will it be mr butcher
what projects have we got on the go do
we have any evidence because that's
quite a large sum of money at the moment
uh believe me i understand we've got to
get uh income coming in and i'm all for
it but i'm not actually just
over the moon that we're going to splash
all that cash without i want to see what
value we're going to get as a council
coming in for that post oh i'm thinking
i'm going to be mr holmes actually who's
going to speak to me there
chairman if i if i can help the answer
mr holmes
thank you yes um obviously we have a
number of commercial projects which mr
butcher is working on
um what we're actually looking to do is
to put an officer in
uh post to actually enable some of those
projects to take forward to business
case and beyond
because clearly we've got a number that
needs some detailed work um to bring
them up to um ready for
members to approve the business case um
and this officer will help
mr butcher get those projects in that to
that position and then start some of
those projects off
it's a very busy team at the moment but
there's also a lot of detailed work and
what we need to do is
to identify um some of the front-running
projects put some time in
develop the business cases and get them
to sign off for remember so that's
really the intention of
that post brilliant chairman can i have
a supplementary to mr holmes please
you can of course cancel them thank you
um mr holmes would the
council uh would the projects be coming
to council in the interim
or will it just be a free reign that the
county you're going to be working on
is it going to come to council or the um
whichever committee it needs to come to
to be discussed
it just concerns me that it may just
happen and i think we really as a whole
council need to be involved in
whatever commercial strategies that
we're going to uh take forward
thank you mr holmes as german yes are
you um absolutely um
all of those projects will come to the
appropriate committee so this is
actually about laying the foundation
supporting the work in to actually get
to a committee or council
to actually put that business case um to
them so yes i can give you that
assurance
excellent well i definitely support it
then thank you mr holmes
thank you council stan and cancer stamp
stole my question
uh so that that would be sorry
yeah so uh
other i can see that there's no other um
members who wish to speak
uh so can i move the two ascent in terms
of this item
noted agreed noted
agreement so
we move to agenda item eight year end
treasury out turn
report 20 19 20 found pages
133 to 142 a reminder that if you wish
to speak on this item
please make this known by using the chat
function i will come to you in turn
mr leslie again please pre-present the
report
thank you the port provides
an overview of the treasury activities
um
for the previous financial year it shows
the type of deposits
that were made summary of the economic
activity
also a report from our treasury advisors
as well
talking about those issues and also
predicting
the or trying to predict to him the
uncertainties around
the future economic outlook going
forward i'm happy to take any questions
do we have any questions for mr leslie
chairman nobody's indicated they wish to
raise a question thank you okay
so the recommendation is that members
review the treasury outright support
return report for compliance
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
and might you may and i can't sound mute
i'm new to my
friends take your name now um i'll do
that
councillor wendy stamp thank you thank
you very much councillor stamp
uh are there so nobody wishes to speak
on
this particular item is that correct
that's correct report noted okay
can i have an ascent for that noted
thank you no tip thank you very much so
we moved to agenda item 9
2012 22 fees and charges policy found on
pages 143-150
members are reminded that if you wish to
speak on this item please make
known by using the chat function within
this meeting i will then come to you
inside
mr leslie please can you present the
report
okay this is an annual report
on the fees and charges policies that
come to the committee
every year you'll know there's been
minimal changes
from past years there has been a change
in terms of the parking
just to make sure that the council's
policy is consistent with his actions
certainly uh around
supporting christmas parking etc around
that so there's an alignment of policies
taking place there that's probably the
one to note
okay thank you very much mr leslie
uh so i've moved the recommendation that
the committee considers the
reviews the suggested fees in charge
charges policy set out
in appendix a for 2122
and that adopts a set of policies for
the officers to follow
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
so i have no seconder for the pubs
chairman for the purposes of discussion
i was seconded but of course
there are some i have some comments and
proposals to make on the basis of it
of course are you happy to second at
this stage counselor's way
yes okay thank you very much
uh thank you i will now invite members
to make any comments on the report
uh can i please uh be advised who has
said they wish to speak uh yes chairman
and counselor lagan
councillor swain and council mrs channel
have indicated they wish to speak
thank you thank you so council lager
yeah thank you chair um the the the
the report um and obviously the set of
policies that has been agreed by
councilman is in existence at the moment
if members remember going back to the
previous
review of warfight which is contained in
appendix
a on on page 147.
i spoke about the reluctance to increase
warfare
on our terms sailing bars fleet uh kept
in malden
um because of the potential pressures
that were honest on them precovered
now i i completely understand and get
the the pressures on us
as a local authority with regard to to
fees and benefits
but i think we really do need to look at
this somewhat differently
in more of a supportive way um to help
keep
the barges and the revenue coming
through from the the
exceptionally high numbers of people
that are attracted to the town
uh for these historic vessels um at the
moment
um topsail charters for instance and
other barges are paying
thousand 1072.50 pence including that
uh for per quarter for mooring uh
at malden key which the charges were
basically looked at
um on economic parity with uh other
marinas in the area
which the barge owners have long said is
not you're not measuring eggs with eggs
it's not parity because we have
i know barges uh marinas and marinas
have facilities
and we don't provide any real facilities
for the barges they basically
do everything themselves um
topsail charters for instance their
income this year has dropped by
70 percent morton district council
who have barges on every single piece of
documentation
uh and it's as it's written everywhere
hasn't supported the barges in any way
shape or form by offering discounts
um the the um the loss of income
that's also been generated by the sb
reminder and the kitty
basically not being housed working on
the key has uh
in effect actually lost us more money
than what we were standing to gain
so i think we need to to have a real
good look at this
and i would like to look at the the
barges
to be able to have a 50 reduction
in the current fees for the year 2021
2022 and then the review at the end of
that financial year
um and i'd also like because obviously
the the small amount of
revenue that that's going to be lost to
the council um
i would like to propose that we ask the
officers steve butchers our commercial
manager
and the the team that's involved there
to look at
other ways of actually gathering um
funds and
charges in that can be there to support
that shortfall
you've got to understand members that
that these barges work incredibly hard
to generate the revenue and are
exceptionally expensive to maintain
and i don't think that we've done the
mainly good in fact
with the previous leadership offered to
have two meetings with the barge owners
as part of the previous recommendation
and those haven't happened
and that's incredibly discouraging to to
the bar jailers and the business people
that they actually are
so members i i would say that um the
majority of
of the fees and charges policies i'm i'm
reasonably content with because they
make sense
um but this one does need a special
laser light lookout
and we should support the barges by by
giving them a reduction
for 2021 2022 and then reviewing after
that thank you
thank you councillor would one of the
officers like to come back and make a
comment about
the warfridge fees
uh yes some i'm happy to comment i mean
we um i think at the moment this is only
the the policy and the fees
for next year haven't been set so i
think um council lagging there is an
opportunity
to feed that into the report process we
were actually putting that together at
the moment
uh with the finance team so um
so so i think with the policy i think
that remains uh as per agreed but yes i
think there's an opportunity for a
discount
um i know you mentioned topsail
previously i i have spoken with them on
a number of occasions
but unfortunately i've been able to meet
with them on a face-to-face basis but
have spoken with them just um just last
week actually
so we are in constant communication with
them and we have offered
support during covid um during the covid
period uh the first lockdown
and that was available to all of our um
uh uh
kind of leases and rentals and
commercial income
but um but that wasn't forthcoming um
they
they chose not to take it at this time
um but but wanted to remain
with that offer on the table so we do
continue to work with them and engage
with them and i'm happy to to um
to discuss the appropriate fee that we
set for the next financial year
uh so i think when we set up the finance
working
sorry god sorry council i just want to
say thanks to steve because obviously
there is the policy
but i also strongly would like to the
the thinking from the officers and
supported by the members if members
choose to do so to support it with that
actual level of reduction
to be built in because obviously steve
you've got to look at the finance and
balance in the book so i appreciate that
dialogue you've had
yeah i was going to suggest it and and
it's uh what mr hope suggests as well
that
uh when we set up the finance working
group this would be something that
the working group can look at
and also i would be very happy along
with any officer
to have a joint meeting with the barge
owners
to discuss things for the future and how
we will work with them in the future
in terms of those fees and i think that
would be something that would be good to
set up yeah as a as an officer and
member
uh meeting yeah
agreed uh just checking out
no he's i'd say you're not making a an
amendment to it
to allow you council lagoon
if the if the the recommendation the
report is just to recommend the policies
what i don't want to do is recommend the
policies and lose the devil in the
detail
i want to be very clear and would like
it minuted that we would
go back to a member working group and
actually look at these charges
with the discounts in mind as being
brought forward because obviously there
has to be
a review to to look at how that could be
replaced without
if i say a penalization of any other
users or any other groups
okay thank you council logan councillor
china
i'm coming chairman that's all right
can you hear me oh good that's right you
can hear me lovely i'm just looking at
my pages
right um okay i'm going to
page like council lag in 1479 and on
148.
um can i just say a general general
thing i think it might be sort of
following on from the the way that uh
councillor lagan's putting a question
he's got specific
i understand we obviously want to retain
a lot of
existing policies and i appreciate very
much the importance of fees
and charges for income basis to the
council
in offices presenting this or the
policies as we see now
has any consideration being given
bearing in mind covered
because there's a wealth of policies in
here and some of them will affect
business
what's consideration given to that fact
bearing in mind the covid
legacy we all probably are aware of and
gonna have
and bearing in mind unemployment
businesses failing and other things
was there consideration to the legacy of
covet if you like
and then chairman just i probably should
know this but um
i'm afraid i apologize that i don't but
i just
want to know on page 147 it refers is to
a third one down off street car park in
malden town maximize
income no free school drop-off permits
and it's got about disabled badge
holders and it says no free parking on
bank holidays and it says here amend
existing policy
income but take into account the need to
support local businesses great
no free school drop off permits then we
move down
to one six eight and we have
uh one two three four five six seven
about the eight one down
or seventh month down parking permits
for schools
chargeable services charges made to
schools parking in mdc
owned car parks now i i just want to
clarify and make sure i do know the
difference between those or is there one
because
i can remember debates within the
chamber both through the old committee
of finance
and the council regarding drop-offs for
mom
you know when mums want to drop children
off and it was at one time we were going
to do away with that there was a bit of
ferrury and then we bought in
the permits so they could get into the
car parks if you like
and utilize them so what is the
difference
so i just understand clearly between
those two policies if you can see
to me um they actually are
could be seen as one and the same um but
i'm not quite sure what off street
parking means when we are talking about
our car parks it would appear
and then we're saying no free drop-off
permit and then we have the charges
there anyway
because there are permits i think given
to the schools or for the mums
thank you councilman uh mr holmes thank
you chairman
um yes uh with regard to the general
question around um
covid well obviously these are the
council's policies regarding its fees
and charges for all of its um
land and buildings and obviously in in
applying those policies and looking at
this
fees that are set there is an
opportunity at that time to take into
account any covered
um implications obviously we're looking
to support um charities and other
organizations going forward so i think
the general policies are set
in terms of the principle that we charge
for instance on some of our sites
is how we then apply that in terms of
the charge itself
going forward so i think that's where we
get the flexibility um and with regard
to the
car parking yes we do make a charge now
to the schools for the permits so there
used to be kind of free
permits that we issued not quite on
demand but very nearly but actually now
we've actually made that through the
the schools themselves and we do make a
charge for it because although
um they are using the car parks twice a
day um for a period of time that they're
making a
contribution to to the costs okay
thank you thank you answer your question
jim i come back
the two policy air sorry the policy fees
and charges that i mentioned one on page
one six seven
one on page six eight yeah are they one
and the same
no they're two separate items so that
yeah so that's what i need to be clear
on what you mean by
no free car parking permits with the
when it mentions the disabled
and then we go because it said we need
to amend that because there's to be no
free parking so we're obviously removing
that and then we go down where we're
mentioning the charging policy
so what is the distinction between those
two areas in terms of the schools
so so what i understand is that
we are for those uh people using the
schools they have to pay for a permit to
go
into the car park what we're doing in
terms of car parking and off street
parking
is reviewing our fees and that's
something we discussed at the kovid 19
reset
meeting this week um so therefore we
will come forward with some
with new ideas about how we charge for
parking in our car parks but there will
be no revision
of free parking for schools is that
correct mr holmes
that is correct
does that answer your question well
it does but i think it's um let's put it
this way
it's amending it but to me we're
charging the schools anyway that's
simply they can come in and drop off
so you're saying you're going to mend
the other policy because we're looking
at saying and no free parking in the car
parks but it does refer to the schools
specifically so i see a bit of
contraindication there if i'm honest
that's the way i read that document okay
okay thank you very much and see if you
can see where i'm coming from maybe it's
my brain
but um i can see a bit of
contraindication or they seem to be one
of the same because we do charge so what
are we saying no free parking we haven't
got it have we
no i i think what we're doing is
separating those two items and
and perhaps that's where the confusion
arises
where is the free parking currently then
we're free so at the moment we have in
in the off street parking there's free
parking for
in certain days for 30 minutes that
people couldn't compart for free
what we are looking at doing is is
revising those parking fees to be
brought forward to council
to review how we support businesses how
we ensure that we keep the high street
alive
and that will be brought forward to
council and to committee next year
when we look at the fees and charges for
car parking
the permits for people for people using
the schools
will remain the same right
okay well yeah to a degree but if we're
saying
no free permits for schools what we're
saying then those schools use the free
permit uh
free bays if those bays were available
they'd be able to use them wouldn't they
well yes but i i think it's specific
about the schools saying
um there is no permits so there is no
free permits for the schools they have
to pay for the permit to use the
car parts well they do yes currently
yeah and
and that we are at the moment saying
that that that policy is staying the
same
well i understand that that's why what
i'm saying of the
the one on page six seven i'm trying to
argument this but it doesn't say
no free no what is it no free use of
whatever the
the schools but we don't because we
charge anyway they come into our car
parks and they have to have the permits
up front
to allow the drop off maybe it's the way
policy is worded
my yeah i i find it confusing chairman
my brain probably but that's how i find
it
okay thank you councillor jenna
councillor swain
thank you chairman yes switch off your
camera mike please cancel a channel
sorry thank you to cancer this way navy
to you
yes thank you chairman yes um i want to
refer to three of the items and in fact
one of them
was uh was warfage um
and it the policy is to
set fees as comparable or
in relation to alternative locations
um and i think from what um
council leggett has implied that's the
really aren't any
identical ones um so it's very difficult
to find it comparator for
um malden um but i think that
to give mr butcher perhaps a rational
mechanism and if any sort of
comparative orphanage fees are
um what you say calibrated to the
limited time
that the barges have available for use
of the um uh the wharf
might take into account um the
comments that council nagin has made in
reducing
the nominal level of um of warfights fee
so i think take into account the
time available um for use of the wharf
um my main point is concerns
promenade park um the
policy says um the aim for overall 60
cost recovery for promenade park with
car parking being the key contributor
um to my mind um promenade park
and i i thought this somebody did say
that it was actually supposed to
generate net
income and to admit to my mind it is
is something wrong if promenade park
isn't covering
the costs of its operation um i think
particularly car parking should cover
its costs
and i wonder whether the problem here is
not just
income but how we allocate the costs of
the
for running the promenade park and i
wonder whether there's a cost allocation
issue here
um my third one um relates to the pop-up
stalls
charges for pop-up stalls which is in
the care of the
director of service delivery but i do
hope that he will
coordinate fully with the commercial
manager to ensure we get
the the maximum income benefit from
these pop-up arrangements
thank you chairman okay and is there is
there a particular question that you
want someone answered counselors wait
on that well they're really comments as
to how
um well my question is
is there a cost allocation problem
really relating to
the allocation of um the determination
of whether promenade park
contributes net revenue or not yeah i
think
i think in practice this policy should
aim at
public fully covering um at least for
recovery of costs for promote part
thank you council swain uh hit the cap
mr holmes or mr butcher
yeah i'm happy to respond thank you
chair yes i think i think you're right
we do need a bit more clarity and i
think this is um
uh this is something we'll be looking to
do i think with the the financial year
we've just had it's been very
uh difficult to to manage those costs
and allocate them and apportion them in
the appropriate areas but it is
something we're looking to do
uh going forward um to have that
appropriate
income amount and in previous years the
um
from park would have would have achieved
more than uh more than enough income to
um uh to kind of wash its own face in
terms of the
the cost it incurs um
so yeah it's something that it's been
difficult to do this year um
and and you know will have suffered a
loss this year because of the splash
park because of the reduction in car
parking and etc
um but it's something to look to do to
the future and and yes
in response to the um third point yes i
mean richard and i
do work very closely to make sure that
we achieve the best possible income from
the
from the concessions and the pop-ups
available to us but again
that that's something that has been um
very difficult to
achieve this year but looking to improve
on next year okay
to answer your question council this way
uh yes thank you craig um
i'd just like to refer back to the
mortgage one whether um
the any comparative information you have
should be looked at in the light of the
limited amount of
time that um people using the wolf have
to actually
use uh use the black water
yeah i think when the um so i think this
time
last year i think the um benchmarking
exercise was done
on um other wolfage that could take the
barges but not necessarily
had barges in in mud births for them but
i'd be really keen to take this uh
to the to the the members finance
working group
as an opportunity to explore the best
way to to get that charge right for
um for the barges okay thank you doctor
thank you council swain
cancer stand yeah thank you chairman i'd
like to just reassure
councillor swain um chris leslie myself
and another two councillors had a
meeting the other day and the prom park
was actually mentioned
and mr leslie is going to look at having
a conversation or arranging a meeting
with mr butcher
and a few others about looking into the
areas that's just been identified by
councillor swain um there is a lot of
work that could be done
uh but i'm totally on board with what mr
butch has just said
it has been a difficult year because of
covid nobody could
foresee it coming but rest assured these
areas that need looking at have been
identified by the officers
and the councillors not just this
administration but the previous one
and we will be certainly working hard uh
to reassure mr sway
katzler swain and the residents thank
you chairman thank you cancer
and yet i'd just like to second that we
need to ensure that we look after
and support our community and what
represents our community
and i'm sure uh as we move forward we'll
be able to work
with uh the warfish fees and with the
barge owners to come up with the right
solutions for everybody
so uh i think somebody who wants to
speak so
can i take that again as an ascent
and uh make that report noted
great thank you very much members noted
so we now move to item number 10 uh
which is capital project bids for
2012 22 20 that's 22 21 22.
i didn't read the notes right then found
on pages 151-192
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the chat function
within the meeting i will then come to
you in turn
and please keep your points clear and
succinct mr leslie could you please
present the report
so the report sets out the capital bids
that will come forward
as part of the capital program uh for
next year
again this is coming to committee ahead
of
january to allow time for uh proper
engagement around these matters so again
this is uh one
more for noting but to allow sufficient
time for members
to probably consider the items ahead of
january and having input
into that so really just happy to take
any questions
and are there any other officers who
would like to speak about any of the
capital expenditure
at this stage
was it just mr leslie at this particular
point
oh got a couple of your pop-up uh mr
butcher i saw you first
are you mike's on your microsoft mr
butcher only that we're happy to answer
any questions that counselors might have
in
relation to the uh um the capital
requests we've submitted
okay thank you very much mr holmes
thank you chairman and obviously just to
point out where we've identified
projects as being
essential or a service improvement um or
commercial and you'll see those uh
in the project categories so we've
broken them down into the various sites
and then given that members of you on uh
priorities as well
thank you thank you very much mr holmes
and i have uh councillor durham as the
first person to speak
thank you chairman it's just a very
quick question to um
the lead finance officer could could you
just tell me what our
earmarked and unallocated reserves are
at present please
thank you so we've got an estimated in
terms of the general fund
uh period we've got about four million
projected
by the uh end of the year in terms of
the general fund which is the
unearmarked
in terms of the year marked um
i've got in front of me but we're
looking at about i think probably around
the same
same amount about four million but
probably right in front of me at the
moment
to happy to take offline or come back in
a
minute
[Music]
it would be interesting to yes it would
be interesting to know because
uh when the local government reform
um was being discussed and
and figures were being exchanged between
all districts and the county that
the levels for reserves both sets were
considerably lower than that so you can
come back to me at a later date it's
absolutely fine
but i would like to know what the exact
state of play is please
yeah absolutely fine and we did actually
put into the lgr work
for that so it's no problem chairman
can i come back can i come back see
because you weren't next counselor
channel
no it's just on that chairman will all
the committee have that figure supplied
to them as well chairman
mr leslie
uh yes it's absolutely fine okay thank
you
councillor skeens yes thank you um a
couple of items
from page excuse me page
one five two or uh let me see if i look
yes the river bailiff a new vehicle uh
this
listed at the bottom of vehicle and
plant replacement first of all isn't
river
baylor still nigel harman has that
changed and
uh what what's the why does he need new
vehicle
and that's the first question and the
second question is
uh rivers on the same page burnham
crouch houseboats birth i don't think
that's in
my neck of the woods i this weskey i
think this refers to the new houseboat
birds
um which are being proposed down at the
world war memorial a hundred and twenty
thousand pounds seems
a lot i was just wondering what the
background of that was okay
so what i would suggest then is that if
we can keep
to the essential items first of all
and then we'll come to the commercial
project as a separate item with mr
butcher
so we'll start with the questions about
the uh bailiffs vehicle uh who'd like to
answer that question
thank you chair i'll i'll answer that
question for you uh yes the rif bailiff
still is
nigel hammer um the
need for a new vehicle is around uh
particularly moving the navigation boys
uh we've also changed our vehicle fleet
around slightly so the vehicle that
nigel has had
for the last few years is now with
another team
um so we're we're looking to replace
that vehicle
if possible okay
thank you mr wilson and
we had uh councillor channel did you
have another question
um yes chairman the first one was really
just bearing moment counselor jeremy
asked and that's been confirmed the
whole committee will get that figure
um yes it's to do with page 151 on the
project list it's the employee laptops
replacement
rolling program um 47 000.
can i just ask what we do with our old
laptops please
uh is that mr holmes should answer that
happy to answer that [ __ ] mr leslie
thank you yep
um so currently we do have
uh some that are uh
redundant in terms of outdated and
we're going through a sifting through
some of the it stopped to see what we
can do with it in terms of any disposals
and that will be in accordance with the
contract procedure rules
around that so we'll follow that which
does require it
to be uh i believe firstly offered to
the parishes in accordance with that
and then to be uh disposed of in terms
of best value
going forward oh all right then chairman
i'll tell you why i was bit naughty
possibly
only um and i declared my interest
earlier non-peculiarly modern from
moving into bikini now but
essex county council have a program
whereby laptops
supplying laptops to um you know re-jig
laptops or whatever to young people
bearing in mind with the code giving
young people the opportunity to have
access that's all i just wondered
i wanted to make sure we were getting
the best benefits out of perhaps the
reusage and hearing it goes to the
parish is a good one so
i just wondered if there was a big
write-off figure
uh you know 47 000 pounds to do the
rolling program but
in write-off terms okay i appreciate
somewhere old i just wanted to make sure
perhaps if they can be utilized
elsewhere
and you know as you just said mr leslie
about best value and other things
hopefully
they can be so thank you thank you
council channel
counselor helm
thank you mr chairman i refer to page
158
there's a lovely picture of a green
tractor on agricultural tyres are we
going into agriculture now or
should that be on grass tyres or is that
the size of tractor we're looking at
please mr wilson
um as as with some previous reports we
use an example picture of what we're
looking to
okay so yeah we do use it largely for
grass work and for mowing
so we're not ignoring that size yes
absolutely that's not the specific
vehicle that we will be preparing thanks
mr wilson uh councillor stamp
uh thank you chairman i might agree
actually with the council durham i think
it'd be quite important for us to have
the reserves figure the general reserves
in the year marked
um i totally agree with the essential
works
i have got a couple of questions though
about the
service improvement for the gym
expansion for the dengue 100
i think it seems a little bit unless you
build it in for a bit later on in the
year i i don't see that we should be
spending that sort of money or it's
going to be programmed in later
i don't know the exact detail because
it's closed it's got it's costing the
council a lot of money at the moment
anyway
and i don't think that might be
appropriate at the time a couple of
questions for
uh matt wilson if that's okay chairman
the riverside
information boards and signage i thought
that was an allocated budget previously
in previous years
or it came out of a pot of money and so
did the car parking
i can remember us having issues about
the car parking
um and it was never finished properly mr
wilson i think you'll agree
when we went round it was all loose
stone it could be in the wrong area
i'm happy to be corrected but can you
confirm if the money has been allocated
before if this is new council money that
we're actually
talking about allocating for the future
thank you thank you chairman
mr wilson certainly um yes there was a
capital allocation
three years ago for the signage within
riverside park um
through the financial processes last
year that was returned to capital but
to the capital pot this is a
resubmission of the bid so that we can
get those signs
uh back in okay so it's the same project
renewing on that one and the car park is
for it's obviously for a larger sum we
did spend
uh some repairs and renewals money on
the car park lower car park in riverside
park
again about three years ago uh it was
about eight thousand pounds at that time
this is much much larger amount of money
to actually fix the underlying problems
within that one and provide a better
base surface
chairman can i come back please are you
actually going to be able to do it where
you put lines and markings so we can
actually have allocated spaces this year
mr
uh this time mr wilson please
there will be marked spaces within it
yes whether it will be a hard sealed
surface or whether we will
use a loose surface as we have in the
problem uh that can have allocated
parking spaces
um that's still to be determined
depending on costs oh sorry to interrupt
you i'm only concerned because i'm sure
some members may be aware that we've had
the
racing cars uh finding places to
ruin our beautiful parks in burnham last
night
doing donuts and everything and i just
wouldn't really want to give them
another area
to go and burn their rubber or whatever
the saying is at this
this moment in time so i think we just
need to be careful
and think about the possibilities of you
know
don't do something half-heartedly and
half the expense
that you're going to have to do it again
in two years or one year's time and
bring back to this council
for another thirty or thirty five
thousand uh thank you
um chairman and uh mr wilson before i go
to mr butcher
could i go to mr leslie who uh can come
back on the reserves question
yeah thank you chairman um i've got the
figures up in front of myself now i've
managed to get back to the pack and
find them there on page 50 now
and at the end of this year as i said
general fund
about four million and enlightened as i
said um about
four million uh that's on page 50 of the
report on the mtfs so
yeah probably yourself i should go back
and find it now thank you mr leslie mr
butcher
thank you chair yes it was just in
response to the leaders question around
the
um gym expansion at the dingy 100 sports
centre
so i know we've previously spoken about
the rugby club undertaking
some work there and taking over the bar
area
so so what this is what this investment
is and it doesn't fit into any of the
categories we've got it would actually
be an investor save project whereby
we would invest um about 30 000 pounds
we could expand the gym at um at the
denju but also with the rugby club
taking over the new uh
the new expanded bar area we would
actually end up paying
less to places leisure to run that um i
appreciate it's a service improvement
but it didn't
we didn't have a category for that as a
kind of invest to save money
type approach but that's the one we've
spoken about previously
i'm more than happy to support that but
when it said gym expansion
you know what you just described is a
little bit different but thank you for
clarity thank you chairman
okay council logan
yeah thank thank you chair um the the
query i have is about
uh the item for the new uh morgan
problem
uh for the service improvement of a new
improved skate park
for a hundred thousand pounds that seems
an awfully large
amount of money and i'm very much for
improving the resources for for the
youth of the town
but that does seem to be quite a high
figure um and considering we have a
skate park that's well used and well
visited down there
um it's just something that stuck out to
me that that along with the river
bailey's
cost of his vehicle was something that
sort of made me go
really um so if you could give a bit
more information about
why that sum is so high please
mr butcher yes thank you chair
yes um council again we've looked at
other escape well the reason this is on
the list is we've had a number of
public inquiries um councillor mays has
asked us if we could look in
look into other other recent
developments in other districts and
boroughs just to see
just to see what the cost of one would
be um
we appreciate it's a service improvement
it would be um
it would be a whole new skate park that
would that would go in there
um but you're quite right we do have a
skate park um
it is aging and it will need additional
work
to it to doing to it in the future years
um
but but this was more of a request like
i say from from councillor mays and uh
and from a number of quests from the
public to saying would
uh would council consider investing in
something like this
okay so um just for you to chair that is
it's not a done deal it's it's a [ __ ]
thank you yeah these are all things that
we can make a decision on tonight
deciding on where we want to spend
any particular money and whether we
postpone any of these particular items
uh council helm you still have your hand
up is that your legacy hand
thank you uh councillor swain and
councillors wayne that
can you please put your comments in the
meeting chat rather than the chairman
chat
so then it's easy for me to see it i'm
happy well
yes i have to really putting in any chat
actually
seems um we we're not just concentrating
on the essential ones but
um under essential it does seem to me
there's an awful lot of vehicles
what we're trying to um to buy
um and i would like those looked at
to see whether we can put off one or two
of them to
um next year or a future year
um on the prom
park ones i'm assuming that the idea for
a new
skate park would be in the same location
as the existing one
and similarly um with the
galleon which would be most unfortunate
to lose that
it's a very popular item for
young children and i hope that um
well if it can't be replaced with
another galleon that it will be
something that
will fulfill the same sort of function
for the same
age range um as
to these large items um the
skate park and
the houseboat um should we and in view
of what the
mr leslie has shown previously about the
rundown in our capital reserves
uh for projects are these not cases
where we should
think seriously about
borrowing for these large items
so that we do still have something in
the kitty for smaller items
over the next one or two years um
the only uh point about the men's shed
which i agree is a very good project
um i don't know whether the picture
shown in the
um proposal is
the sort of building that's envisaged
but it does seem very large
um and is there an issue with security
the location um
the other the other thing is the prom
park pathway
entrance and this could be a as is noted
an issue um affecting the trees
i wonder if we could look at the
possibility of simply delineating
a pedestrian um pedestrian path
at the side the road is wide enough i
think for a single line traffic
and a pedestrian um
pathway marked on the road i think i
think some of these
these these particular measures
especially the non-essential ones
uh can be taken as part of the working
group
so i think if we focus on on what
expenditure we
we need to decide tonight then some of
these items can be looked at the working
group and brought to the
or back to the committee at a later
stage
so a lot of these like these questions
cancer swain can be discussed as part of
the working group
yes i suppose then the my point would
really be to suggest that
um something on on the um the vehicle
fleet
should be um postponed until next year
okay thank you council swain uh
councillor durham
you wanted to come back yeah thank you
no it's on this
on this subject um thank you chairman
just going back to what councillor
uh china alluded to the the um
the initiative that's being done to
refurbish
um uh laptops they they have they have
used an awful lot from essex but other
authorities as well and i was a bit
surprised that
we haven't um been approached because
they're actually using a malden company
for the refurbishment
so uh 200 odd computers were given out
last week
families that could can't afford it or
need more computers
so and it's a modern business that's
getting getting
that business i just want to go make a
quick comment
john deere tractors are very nice
tractors they're very
expensive tractors uh but uh the dealer
is based in colchester
have we looked at getting a price from a
new holland dealer
who is in our district let's keep the
money
uh as close to home as we possibly can
and do we have to purchase outright why
can we not lease
um these these high uh high value
capital items
um i certainly leased all the tractors
and things when i was buying them
are you councillor durham uh mr holmes
you said you'd be able to answer some of
these questions on vehicles
uh yes i'll ask mr leslie to talk about
leasing arrangements um
i think as we said before that is just
an indicative photo so yes we will go
out to uh procurement
for a tractor we'll be looking to source
locally if we can and obviously
obviously
value for money for the council um i
prefer not to remove
vehicles from the list till next year
there are operational reasons why we
have looked at vehicles but i've already
asked that we do a review
of the numbers to see if we can actually
mix some of the fleet around so
perhaps uh if members agree to have that
working group again we can we'll look at
that a little bit more detail and then
members can consider it as part of the
round that comes in january if that's
okay okay
uh councillor thompson
um sorry chairman thank you i was just
talking in the chat
my points of um are either going to be
looked at
later as part of the working group or
they've just been answered in terms of
the leases so
um thank you there's no need for me to
say anything thank you thank you council
thompson
uh councillor skeens if i come back to
you because you had a question
about the uh the jetty in burnham
uh which would be to cut to mr butcher
yes uh just before that um two uh a
point about um
skateparks and things like that uh we
are being very
malden focused here uh and uh i think we
need to before we start spending our
thousand plus on a new skate park where
there's a perfectly good one in malden
uh there are projects in burnham and no
doubt in other
areas where i think it would be popular
in
and indeed uh right that we uh
thought carefully about uh those uh and
i'm not sure whether we're gonna be able
to put anything into this budget
um i'm just concerned about that because
there was a great talk about
uh refurbishing the burnham um ramps
which are mentioned in here
but and i came up with a quote from from
a
professional company which uh i believe
uh arrived at uh
and with uh mr wilson uh but i've never
heard anything since except there was a
moment when there was likely to be some
106 money
uh a year or so ago but that hasn't
arise
arisen so i am interested in uh
in making sure that we balance uh our
provision of facilities
and don't make it too modern centric
because that upsets everybody else in
the district
and on to the house spokes i don't quite
understand the costs
um you've got 120 000 pounds as a
capital expense i presume this is the
cost of building
a floating pontoon of some sort or maybe
a jetty
i'm not really sure how and why
why that split into ongoing costs over
the next uh
six years um i don't quite understand
that and also with that figure
that's uh quite a lot of money to get
back from
moorings where i'm not quite sure what
you're going to be charging but it
sounds like a lot so i'll be interested
to
understand the thinking behind the house
both
the four house houseboat births that are
being considered down at the war
memorial
thank you council skins councillor
butcher
and councillor mr butcher even and mr
wilson i made you councillors now
sure if if i can take on the skatepark
concern of council skins um
yes there is a section 106 plot uh part
that is due to come in uh from a local
development within burnham
uh the maintenance officer and i have
been out on site in the last month
to discuss where some of the projects
that could be covered
uh which include the skate park within
riverside park so it's
it's still on our list it's still on our
agenda
sorry specifically the bmx track uh i'd
sent
over a couple years now
a quote from a professional company who
had done similar work in chelmsford
i'll send that again for you to have a
look at might be it might be worth
considering the maintenance officer and
i have discussed a
pump tracker effect similar to the one
of great battle that you share there yes
but also the skate park itself and
potential expansion and replacement of
play equipment in that area
okay thank you thank you mr wilson um mr
butcher
yeah if i can just respond thank you
chair if i can just respond on the
houseboat berth this is one of the um
well this is one of the first commercial
business cases that we've pulled
together
um so to behind what you're seeing in
the report there is a
business case that sits behind that that
has some uh robust financial analysis
and assumptions in it we're probably
being cautious
on the costs but that will include the
pontoon and new walkway and or
utility connections uh including
wastewater which isn't um
necessarily required for the for the
births at the moment but it's something
we would like to install
uh for the future births we have a um
a return on investment um pitched in
between year five and year six
for this hundred and twenty thousand
pounds and this is based on um
on roughly um about a five hundred pound
um
birth per month but we have done that on
a worst case
uh best case and likely case scenario so
we we've done various models to see
when we will get our money back from
this investment but but in essence i
mean this will be turning
capital money into revenue income for
the council and long after
we've got the return on investment then
we'll continue to generate revenue
income for
many many years to come i think there's
a small amount of um
maintenance uh that we've included on
there um which i think is about a
thousand pounds every
every couple of years uh again this
isn't the type of project that
of um uh that i'm not necessarily an
expert in
um but i'm working with uh matt wilson
and nigel harmer
um and um yeah we feel like it's uh we
feel like it's a good commercial
uh opportunity for the council to follow
i would just say that that's 6 000
pounds per vote per year
right sorry 500 pounds per month
for what for the birth
for a single birth or for all four
births
for a single so that's six thousand
pounds a year roughly isn't it so
that's quite high for a houseboat birth
i have to say but
if you if you think the market's there
for it then i'm interested to see how
that goes
yes thank you council skins we believe
it is like i say this is a um
a bold project and an uh quite an
exciting project for
um for me and my colleagues but um there
will be
there will be a little bit of give and
take and we won't know what the demand
is until we're
until we're fully built but we are uh we
are proposing a a really nice scheme
down there and i'd be
more than happy to to show you uh some
of the details on that and any of the
other um burnham on crouch
ward members i'll be delighted to see
them thanks
thank you mr butcher uh i will not go to
councillor white as she's not asked a
question previously councillor white
uh thank you mr chairman i'm sorry i've
got a bad reception so i can't
and turn my video on and i also have um
a few concerns
relating to the housework births i mean
i really like the idea of them
with the heritage that we have however
i'm concerned
that the maintenance charges are very
very low as we all know the damage water
does
to anything that's anywhere near it um i
think
that needs a review and i also think
alternative that the estimated charges
are very high
bearing in mind we have quite a lot of
boats and
admittedly it's in scotland but we also
have births for boats
and although it's a different area we
the charges are very very different
and um i would have thought that we'd
have um accounts from other similar
houseboat
um suppliers to actually compare the
charges before doing the business plan
because
i would expect that they are um based on
fact
rather than complete projector and and i
would be surprised that if we get that
much money unless it's including
all utilities and disposal of sewage etc
um because most people have boats
because of the mobile lifestyle and
because of the freedom it gives them
and generally they wouldn't want to pay
a mortgage
cost on a boat birth that they're my
concerns were they fact-based
where were these facts taken from um
because we should be based them on hard
facts before we lay out the money
against the taxpayer and
what are the associated maintenance
costs with the
projects that have been reviewed before
pricing up our project because i think
they are very light
and counts like mr butcher
yes thank you councillor white we we
have done some uh
due diligence and some benchmarking we
um we feel that there is the demand
there we have had several offers already
in fact we've had one offer
um for a 10 year for two births up front
uh to the tune of a hundred thousand
pound and i appreciate that
um there's a long way to go from an
offer verbally to actually having a
written contract for that
um but but our understanding and and um
from nigel hamer uh is that there are
a lot of house a lot of house boats
looking for births that are being forced
out of london
um and um and the proposition of burnham
on crouch would be
uh very appealing to them
councilwoman does that answer your
question yeah well if i might come back
but
have we actually although we have two
from london that would be fantastic
to encourage people into our district
and yes i agree
burnham would be a good place to have
them but we mustn't price out locals
and can you tell me how it compares to
the mooring charges for houseboats in
places like all thorn
and mainland um and also
where the maintenance charges are
compared with what are the comparable
charges for other
moorings this is my concern is that it
just i mean maybe i'm wrong i mean
i think it's spectacularly like the
maintenance because i know
personally that maintenance charge is
spreading with water is very high and
i would just like it to tell me we've
we've we've taken
studies from five essex houseboat
mooring
companies and these are charges and
that's what their maintenance have been
in year one
year three year six so if i can just
respond
um councillor white i think we have done
that that comparison piece of work
i don't have it to hand but but as i
said earlier i'm more than happy to take
any councillors through the business
case and the work that we've done
so far um and i take on board your
concerns with the maintenance and
if you i mean as i said i'm this is um
an area of my expertise and if you if
you've got some knowledge on the
maintenance and fees that we
you think we should be prudent to
include i'd be more than happy to
include those
okay thank you mr butcher uh councillor
stan
thank you that's not a problem but i
would like to have these reports before
we get to the budgetary meeting because
having them afterwards is a bit
unhelpful
yeah thank you councillor white
councillor stamp
uh thank you for coming his comeback
chair i'm just going to actually ask
mr holmes uh because he obviously wants
the vehicles and i think for very good
reasons
are we going to look at electric
vehicles please uh we're not going to go
for petrol or diesel are we are we
actually going to look at if we are
going to invest
in vehicles i'm sure we need to actually
follow what's going to be our own
climate strategy or what's coming from
central government because they're all
going to be phased out but i think in
20 20 20 30.
um so have we looked at that please
thank you chair
chairman we will be reviewing our fleet
and absolutely we will look to see
what's most appropriate
i think uh some of the vehicles that
we're replacing actually are slightly
more difficult to do as an electric
vehicle so they carry
grass cutting equipment and there are
larger vehicles that we have
but absolutely we've got some small vans
which will be coming up um
things are used by our community
engagement team for instance so
when they come up in their lifestyle so
like replacement then obviously we can
look at those so
yes we will look and if it's appropriate
um we'll look to see if that's possible
thank you thank you chair mr holmes i
really think it's important um
maybe not just appropriate as if we can
actually start to make a statement
um and you can always come back to
council if it's going to cost a lot more
money and let members decide but i
really think it's important we start to
look at
um electric vehicles i know you can't do
for the big ones i appreciate that
thank you
uh i think that's everybody's honest
question and
and i did i did it wrong i didn't do the
recommendation first
so the recommendation is that the
committee has obviously reviewed the
project bits out and
set out an appendix a in preparation to
recommend a twit oh miss counselor
edwards
very quickly please
yeah sorry about that i was having
trouble with the chat uh
just going on further from a cancer
stance
question and looking at the the latest
information coming out regarding the
2030 electric vehicles one of the things
we are lacking
perhaps an investment or should be
thinking about are charging points
that's the big uh sticking point i think
thank you okay and obviously we do have
charging points at the council officers
so that yeah that might help us in terms
of that
yeah we can install them in perhaps on
the prom or somewhere like that there's
one there and there's one in lidl but
that's it yeah
thank you mr holmes did you want to
respond at all to that
uh just to say that obviously we're
looking at our climate strategy we
recognize that there's a need not only
for the council but obviously for our
customers in car parks so
absolutely um we are looking looking to
see what we can do with that as well
i think councillor lagan did you cancel
your question that it had been answered
i did chair thank you very much okay
thank you very much
so if i go back to the recommendation
that the committee reviews the project
bid set out which is what we have done
um in the preparation to recommend the
2122 capital programme
at the strategy resources committee in
journey21
for approval by the council in february
2021
would any member like to second that
motion please if you could turn on your
video and unmute your microphone
i'll second it thank you very much
so uh can i take that recommendation
via ascent yes agreed
agreed oh great if i could just ask
a week please chair yeah i think you're
too late council lagoon
i just wanted to be clear on on the the
recommendation
so the recommend so the recommendation
is
thank you thank you council again the
recommendation is that with this
so we've had the discussion now that
will go to the working group
we will come back to the committee in
january with the finalized capital
expenditure
which we will then agree at that point
and once that's agreed it will go to
council in february
perfect thank you okay
and council white as councillor
thompson's uh just pictured you have a
legacy hand
okay so item number 11
is uh the finance members working group
found on pages 193-194
remember as a reminder that if you wish
to speak on this item please make this
name by using the chat function within
this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct mr
leslie please can you present the report
members about forming a finance working
group uh i think you may have seen from
that the reports have come forward
today this certainly is a lot to discuss
for us to consult on
and some questions as well and it seemed
appropriate that there will be
a forum for those informal discussions
that may not necessarily lend themselves
to a committee environment so that
everyone is
informed as well as much as possible as
we take this
um forward so it was really the purpose
of us putting
this forward to members and just to see
if
do you want to try without your cam on
mr leslie
might be yep thank you can you can you
hear me now
yeah okay i'll try again apologies i'm
sure you didn't miss much but i'll try
again
uh just we thought um i want to put this
proposal forward to members
uh have you seen from today there's
certainly a lot to discuss
um and sometimes an informal environment
in order to engage members views
and take profitables forward and is a
good
forum for that uh you've seen obviously
the finances and also the bids have been
put through early so and get feedback
and really want to continue that
consultation engagement with members so
i really want to put that forward for
yourselves to decide if you felt that
was also a good way forward
thank you mr leslie so the
recommendation that sat out in the
report are as follows
item little one that a finance member
working group of six members
be established item letter two that six
member representatives are pointed to
the working group
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone
i'd like to second that please chairman
the councillor schemes thank you very
much
uh i will now invite members to make any
comments on the report
does anybody have any comments
councillor skeets you got your cam on
before you did your typing
i know i'm sorry uh yeah just simply
that
this is obviously a very good idea uh
just the question is where do these um
representatives come from do they come
from across the council are they
um but would it make more makes sense to
have
most of them from the strategy resources
committee who are familiar with the
material
uh what is the form it will it will be a
working group that reports into
strategies and resources
okay so how do people become so what
happens next what uh
the next week we decide on whether we're
going to vote on those recommendations
or we
we amend those recommendations and then
we will point the six members to that
working group
okay thank you uh councillor yeah thank
you chad just want to say it's an
excellent recommendation because as mr
leslie said there's an awful lot
to go through and i found in the past
that there's been so much there you
can't get the
devil in the detail teased out
so i think this is an absolutely superb
recommendation which i fully support
thank you council i can any other uh
council would like to speak
so as chairman i would like to amend
this recommendation
that the six members are appointed to
the working group
and that is balanced with four
independents
and two conservative representatives
can i have a second for that amendment
to appointment
two i'd second that uh
recommendation amendment chairman
councillor stamp thank you councillor
stamp
uh so what i'd like to do is uh
move that to the vote and i just want to
query in terms of the process uh
when do we appoint the six members is it
after
the vote or before the vote
and chairman i would suggest i mean it
would be after because you've got to
establish the principle of the working
group
first okay so we'll establish principal
working group first uh
so in terms of the the recommendation
are we
would you like to do this for a recorded
vote or via ascent
chairman can i just chip it can i just
ask whether
whether the independent the the
non-aligned or whatever they're called
group get any positions on this
uh well at the moment i propose that
there are four independents uh it really
does depend on
whether you want to have two
conservative positions or one
conservative position
and one democratic alliance group
representation
councillor china uh thank you chairman
just so i'm clear on that you're
proposing four independents and two
conservatives or four independents and
one conservative and
one you're saying the other alternative
could be one conservative and one
uh one um
right correct i was thinking it might be
uh put forward as even stevens
uh three independents and three
conservatives but
obviously not
so would do so there's a recommendation
on the table
are we saying that we are going to have
a vote on that recommendation or do we
take it by ascent
i'm happy to take it by a cent but if if
anybody else wishes to ever recorded
vote chairman that's down to them but
they need to speak up
so i i take that as the silence is that
we are taking that via ascent as nobody
has asked for a recorded vote
uh so that recommendation is passed
and i would like from the chair
before independence for that
working group to be myself
councillor lagan councillor stamp and
councillor swain
so can we have the two names of the
conservative nominations um well i would
propose myself
and um councillor durham
can i politely decline that council
chance very kind of you but um
it's not really my thing okay in that
case i would propose myself
and councillor white
i'm happy speaking for me i'm happy with
those councilmen channel thank you
just to confirm that we are following
correct constitutional procedure
can i have a cent for those
recommendations first of all
agreed agreement that has counsellor
white agreed
against yeah yes i agree
okay so we have one against and the rest
are
innocent so councillor helmer are you
asking for a recorded vote
well chairman i would like if i'm my
chairman yes my clinical difference
whether i ask for a recorded vote or not
because you've already decided what
you're going to do thank you okay
councillor chana well i was going say
chairman you you kept with the six
um if the democratic alliance would like
to see could we not make it
seven i'm not sure where the figure six
has come from really
i think it came from mr leslie
right and i'm happy to support
councillor chana to amend the working
group numbers to seven
so if we amend the working group members
to seven so
and i'm happy to second that so that we
have a democratic alliance on there
okay so therefore the recommendation
now is that it will consist of seven
members
representatives are pointed to the
working group
four independents two conservative
and one democratic alliance
and will there be substitutes allowed if
members are not allowed to
uh not able to attend the working group
uh is that normal on working groups
is it no yes there's no reason why not
i believe that you can in working groups
i was asking the question because it
wasn't in the report sorry chairman
isn't that a separate proposal
just hold on a minute chairman as long
as it's constitutional i don't have a
problem with it i'm sure the other
members don't
in case somebody can't make it at the
moment everybody's busy chairman so
it's a working group to work for the
council if members want to substitute
and it's not breaching the constitution
or the terms of reference when they're
written
and go to council for approval i'm more
than happy thank you council of china so
now
so now we have so we have the centered
the recommendation
is that correct are we in agreement for
the recommendation
that a group is established it consists
of seven members
four independents two conservatives
and one democratic alliance can i have a
cent
agreement so
the members of that working group are
councillor councillor stamp councillor
lagan
councillor swain could i have the names
of the two conservatives please
well i think um i did um
come up with um initially myself
counselor durham
and councillor white councillor durham
said it wasn't his thing
so i guess that leaves um the two names
so they could you confirm those names
please counselor channel
well it's the it's the names without
counsellor daramin um
uh councillor and uh right
yes so councillor channel and councillor
white
are the representatives from the
conservative group
councillor helm as you are the only
member from the democratic alliance on
this committee
we will put in your name forward is that
correct
thank you very much chairman you're very
welcome
thank you okay
item number 12 uh
which is modern citizens advice request
for review of funding found on
pages just before you move on and you
just need to agree that those members
okay sorry sorry sorry that's okay so
do we have a cent for those seven
members
thank you very much so now i can move on
to item number 12.
which is more than assisted advice
requests for review funding
found on pages one nine five two one
nine seven
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this name
by using the chat function within this
meeting i will then come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct mr leslie could you please
present the report
yeah sherman if i'm i think it's myself
that's going to happen oh okay
sorry i had you down at mr leslie down
mr homie
yes uh short report members for
consideration this evening and we have
had an approach from modern citizens
nice bureau regarding future funding
and that is included in the reported
appendix one but i do believe we have a
speaker from the citizens of ice
uh here this evening who would like to
make a very short presentation to the
committee
to support their request as detailed in
the report
so i wonder if it might be appropriate
this time to
ask the ciab representative to to make
their presentation then i can
wrap up the report at the end of this
convenient thank you mr holmes yes uh
members we have mr philip wakeling
chairman of the malden district
assistance advice
in attendance i've agreed for mr
wakeling to make a short presentation
mr wakeling please could i ask you to
now make your presentation
yeah thank you very much mr chairman and
members um now the essence of our
proposal
is for a new three-year contract with
the district council
for the provision of generalist advice
the reason why this is particularly
important to us at the moment is that
we're about to make proposals to renew
our contract with the national lottery
for specialist debt homelessness
prevention and welfare benefits
we're aiming for another five year term
with a lottery worth 350 000 pounds
and we want to be able to demonstrate we
have secure funding in place with the
district council
for delivery of core services for at
least the greater part of that term
in essence we can't provide specialist
advice without being able to demonstrate
that we can provide
generalist advice significance to the
lottery contracts to
malden and the district is under the
current uh
contract with the lottery we prevent
homelessness
for over 30 families every year we coach
around 100 families in tenancy
and housing related issues to help them
secure or retain their homes
we achieve benefit gains within the
order half a million pounds every year
by appealing incorrect decisions and we
anticipate that most of this money will
be spent in the district
over the life of the contract we expect
that around 400
families will gain additional income
through successful resolution
of complex benefit cases and appeals
whilst 350 will report improved
well-being
and a further 320 disabled people we're
more able to afford the care
and the help that they need we
additionally managed to write off
in the order of half a million pounds
worth of unmanageable debt
every year but more importantly around
250 people each year
going through us an understanding of how
to manage their money
and avoid future indebtedness with
consequential benefits for family
relationships
and both physical and mental health so
in summary
if we're able to grant us a new
three-year term with some inflation
protection built in
it'll put us in a far better place to
achieve this vital renewal with a
lottery
it's worth noting the lottery doesn't
renew contracts as a matter of course
and so we want to make their decision as
straightforward as possible
additionally services which we provide
cannot be obtained from any other source
in the district not least because we
have to be fca accredited
and regulated in order to provide the
debt advice
so we'd very much welcome your help with
this renewal thanks very much
thank you mr whaling council channel
could i please ask you to turn your
camera off
oh sorry chairman i thought i had beg
pardon
thank you oh and my mutes sorry
uh so the recommendations are
that members item little one
consider the request from malden systems
advice at appendix one
little two confirm if they wish to
increase funding to mold and cited
advice
from seventy three thousand five hundred
to seventy five thousand for twenty one
twenty two consider funding for twenty
two twenty two onwards as part of a
report
on future procurement to be brought back
to the strategy resources committee
in spring 2021 if any member wishes to
second that emotion
please turn on your video and unmute
your microphone and state your name now
please
nick skeen seconded thank you very much
councillor skeens
so the first person i had to speak with
councillor white
um thank you mr chairman um now i
think that this item needs to be
deferred um now i've spent a lot of time
in the past
working with the cab and i know they do
a very valuable job
however my my main
concern is also for the taxpayers in
their district and getting value for
money
that being said i'm not disputing cab do
a good job
but every other authority i'm sure mr
leslie can confirm
to me it only gives about 20
of the funding for the citizens advice
bureau bearing in mind we have few
reserves left
and every year we've been assured by the
citizens advice bureau that they're
going to
gain extra external funding and to be in
line with all of the other cabs
in the uk we are the only authority that
gives such a high percentage of funding
which
and my the reason this needs to be
deferred is we don't even have the
financial figures
in the report this evening um now if we
go on past figures we've generally been
funding it about 80 percent
and every other local authority fund
runs at 20
and the cabs make up the 80 percent and
my other concern is we have
no and every time this comes before us
the officers assure us they're going to
give us
detailed figures and generally i've
managed to get them included
but sadly not this year um the other
issue i have
is the rental charges for their offices
in malden district council
if you go to the chelmsford cab which is
much much larger than malden
they include the rental charges within
the funding
that they get so in other words to to
account legally
as everybody will know as accountants
you can't just lose bits of money
because they're inconvenient
the rental charge should be put down as
a charge the cab
and then it should be listed as funded
by molten district council otherwise
this is tax evasion because you're not
giving clear figures
now i don't know if this has changed but
i suspect this money is
on top of the 73 000 so i imagine it
will
actually be about 120 000 pounds worth
of funding
um now we don't give any other charity
free support and free accommodation um
and i've had it raised from other
charities well why does cab get free
offices can't we also have free offices
um so i think this needs to be looked at
um and um you know i i think this needs
to
go back to the um working group for
assessment
um maybe i'm wrong with the previous
figures i don't know
um it needs to go back to the working
group to be assessed
um you know because if i'm wrong and if
we we have sorted the funding
then fine like can i stop you then and
ask mr holmes to come in and
answer some of those questions
thank you chairman um yes well the
purpose of the report really was to look
at a one-year extension i think for the
very reasons you've identified regarding
value for money
and we do need to assure that we are
receiving value for money for the
service and many of the things you've
spoken
about this evening would be included in
that review so pragmatically we
we looked at the uh the fact that we
need to do that procurement exercise
we obviously looked at the cabs request
for their initial help in the first year
and felt that was the middle ground
where we would
recommend that you and perhaps consider
that increase um but obviously then
allowing that more detailed review
um and value for money exercise to be
carried out before we make a
commitment to the future we obviously
understand the civ need a longer period
of
time to plan and work um but obviously
we do need to make sure
we are getting that value for money so
really essentially that's what those
recommenders were recommendations were
setting out to do
um but obviously we now have a working
group which could actually do
some work on that uh perhaps between now
and the next uh report which will come
in in january
uh for members with the detail perhaps
they're looking for thank you mr holmes
does that answer your questions yes
um it it does and it doesn't because
you know we are meant to be setting the
budget here and we don't even have
any accounts we have nothing to decide
and
we we initially gave them 10 000 people
so could this go to the working group
before a decision is made
on funding this we so we are we are
setting our budget yeah in terms of the
cab
and we're doing a provisional agreement
for that first year
and then it will come back and we'll
will have further detail for future
years
and also looking at if there are any
other providers is that correct mr
holmes
jim if if members were minded then i
think the issue around the
recommendations is that we would
we would put that additional for the
first year into the
um into the growth items that are coming
up before in january so i think between
now
and general you can look at the detail
um if this commit committee is
happy then obviously that can be
included as part of that bid going
forward you
yes yes thank you mr chairman because it
was supposed to happen
last year and it didn't happen so so
hopefully we can resolve that this time
council away
uh council lager
yeah thank you mr chairman well i
vehemently disagree with
council hawaii i really don't care what
others do i actually care what this
district does and with the decisions
that this council makes
and i feel that the the council should
support the the requirements and the
the bid that the citizens of vice bureau
have put in i think it's probably
more important when you drill down and
look into the work that they provide
across the district
and the actual cost savings that they
make by the service that they provide
um mental health now is probably more
more important than ever
with covid19 and the uh the challenges
that's brought across
many graphs of society so um
i think that you know again me it's a
as a small amount of money um that is
clearly been identified and we should
support it
and just remember that the previous
conservative administration
has given out interest-free loans to
people like stone mary's to support
fantastic initiatives okay thank you
thank you council
and if we can and if we can't if we
can't thank you if we can't support this
initiative then there's something wrong
in my view
okay thank you council logan councillor
skeens
yeah uh i'll be brief uh fantastic value
for money from cab uh i utterly support
the proposal
and uh uh that's it really and i support
what council lagging says too
okay thank you councillor schemes
councillor helm
[Music]
thank you mr chairman i want to come
back a bit on what councillor white has
said
basically they're rent free rate free
heating free
lighting free so that all adds up to a
tremendous amount of money
it might be value for money but it's
still an awful lot of money
thank you thank you councillor helm
council thompson
sorry bit slow with the master chairman
thank you um
yeah i must admit i would like to see
more funding
to the cab you know if it's additional
funding to
what we already do that would be
fantastic if it would come from outside
the council because
we are kind of taking it from one hand
to give it to the other you know if it's
residents money that's going back
out to residents um that doesn't
entirely make sense to me
however moving on from there one
question
um is do we in fact charge for rent and
then grant it back
and and if we do does the 75 000
odds that we're looking at include that
or is it
free rent clusters um
and the other question is you know i
really would like to support this i'm
keen to
but at some point we're going to have to
look at what we don't do in order to
fund it it's not a vast amount
and we've got lots of service
improvement items to look at what is the
working group house so
i do hope very much it can be done but i
would appreciate knowing if you do in
fact charge for rent and regret it
thank you chairman thompson uh mr holmes
or mr leslie
can you answer that question
sorry chairman just i'm using my
understanding
is that we don't charge directly is part
of the package that we provide the
accommodation but i will confirm that uh
tomorrow and send a note to confirm that
that's my belief
thank you mr holmes thank you chairman
thank you
councillor thompson councillor channel
thank you chairman i'm sorry chairman
i'm going to have to use my mobile like
i've been using because showing this
screen
as it went earlier i can't seem to keep
the document up and then be
flicking between the two so i've got the
report on my mobile
and forgive me if i don't get it quite
right because this prints quite slow but
that's what i've been having to do for a
little bit now
um i would say regarding the cab and we
had the discussion in the chamber
it was relatively recent if you recall
where
maldon district council had reduced the
money we gave to the cab
and then we had the debate in the
chamber recently because they did ask
for the reinstatement
and actually there was agreed that we
would do because
i think i mean i hear what councilor
white said and i can understand wanting
to get the clarity on the figures
absolutely regarding and
um you know the the rent and other
issues and council helms made that point
but we did agree at council to actually
support that and i think what it is i
must declare i suppose that although i'm
appointed by the council i sit on the
cab liaison group and
i have visited the cab and i think i
said it at that meeting
um the reason why i'm supportive of the
cab because i really and
did not have a total comprehension of
just exactly
what they did and really what it meant
for the district and our residents by
having a cab that is very active
and supportive and because of the money
we give
and i i think with the covid times and i
think the appendix actually highlights
this
we have yet to really face um the legacy
of what kovid may
give mean to this district um and
therefore
that's why i'm really giving great
consideration to this
now i can say the reason largely why the
council did also agree to give that
money and go back to where we were was
because of the transformation process
um and i have to say this without the
cab being there
and i i'm sue green's not here tonight
but
she did actually respond at that time it
was the cab actually that we had to
utilize very much to assist
certainly with certain service areas in
fact our homelessness i think the
support given
enabled us to really be efficient and
effective for that time
um so therefore and i hear what mr uh
holmes said and that was something i was
going to say
bearing in mind councillor white's
concerns and now we hear from councillor
helm
that i think by i i can see why the
three years is required and i probably
would
probably be supportive of that however i
think mr holmes explained
my thinking here and what council white
said if we agree to one and then make
sure we have
um a look at it all through the
procurement process
that will give the answers also to some
of the things that counselor white has
actually um said she feels should have
been actually before the committee
tonight
okay thank you council channel points
uh councillor stamp um councillor
channel has actually
said nearly everything i wanted to say
and i thank her for it i think that's an
excellent excellent speech i have a
query though
um the gentleman who did the
presentation and forgive me i'm rubbish
at names
he said it was to get a three-year
lottery funding
if we only agree to do it for one year
chairman does that affect his
application to the lottery
to getting his lottery funding it could
do yes councillor stanford
clarity though please because i think
that is important on how
we may vote chairman thank you and i'm
sorry to interrupt you
that's okay uh my that's my
understanding
uh mr holmes is is my understanding
correct
uh yes jim i think you are correct um i
would say you're not um
you still have time this budget won't be
set this evening um obviously we're
taking this forward to
to january and february so um you know
we can go away and do that dialogue now
with the cab so we can be very clear
what the implications are
um for members and then through the
working group and then back to
back to this committee but um you know i
think we have to acknowledge we need to
do
some procurement work um and it does
need to go through the normal budget
process which is this is this is the
start of really so um
but we can talk about the details and
timings do we know
the the deadline for the cab to
do that in terms of the lottery do we
know what their deadlines are
and if we don't can we make sure that we
have those
you know so that we can make a a good
decision
yes of course and if it is urgent and
obviously we can we can look at that
separately but yes we'll do that
thank you very much mr holmes uh
councillor swain
uh thank you chairman um yes i
was concerned about that point that um
it looked like the cab needed to have a
three-year arrangement in order to get
the lottery funding um but if
a decision isn't essential tonight then
i would go along with the um further
investigatory
work as far as it can be done because i
think it is very difficult to try and
put up
that put put this um the cab through a
cost benefit analysis from
the council's point of view um and there
is also the question of um
uh utilization of the district council
space
uh in a sense um they um
they are not costing the council much by
occupying part of the space
um but in general i would support the
idea of
their three-year agreement okay thank
you councillor swain
uh mr holmes in in terms of the
three-year funding would we be able to
get that procurement process and
analysis done by
february's snr meeting
um i don't believe we can um because uh
this is a quite a large piece of work
and i i know uh i've spoken to be
screened around it and
looking at her recommendations here is
that um she'd be looking to do that by
the spring of 2021
spring was the thing that i was trying
to be a bit more concrete about
yes indeed i understand the issue um i
think obviously we will look at the
timetable and revisit that for you
and to see how quickly we could do that
and that exercise because obviously i
appreciate you would want to make a
decision
um in the full knowledge of what the
review might say so i can't give you a
promise this evening but i will
take your you know kind of wish away to
see what i can do with it okay
thank you are there any other
counselors who members would like to
speak council
suede if you come back or or if you're
visiting
um it's this question of a procurement
process
i mean um are there any um
serious alternative sources that provide
the same range of
um information and help that the cab
does
mr holmes i would agree it is difficult
to find
alternative providers obviously other
cabs in the past have
potentially looked to providing services
in other locations that that's a
possibility
um if it turns out that there is not
the ability to do that uh competition
then obviously perhaps it becomes more
of a negotiation and i think we've done
a really good job working with the cb
in setting up a service level agreement
to look at the performance
and also talks about the contribution
that's made so
if if competition is difficult um or not
possible then there's still a way to
work with the cab but
we i think we simply need to do that
review to establish where we are really
so that's perhaps something that can
come to the working group as
you know once we we move that process
forward that the working group
could be shown whether there are
alternatives
and that way we can move it quickly back
to committee if necessary
yeah we can do that that's fine thank
you very much
okay so we come to
the vote on the items and
uh yes
sorry did someone speak that there's
some whispering going on chairman
whispering campaign
i i suddenly heard something then it
wasn't yes well chairman i will admit to
these things
i my came off and i was just asked a
question
by my husband if i wanted a cup of tea
can you can you get me one please
obviously that's extremely important
having a cup of tea
yes me too please he's seeing me
balancing a mobile in one hand and
looking at a screen with the other so
i think he's being kind thank you
councillor channel so
in in terms of the recommendations uh
again are we happy to do that via ascent
uh or do we wish for a recorded vote
and do we want to take the items
altogether or
separately can we take separately
chairman
um and could you say what they are
because i'm
yeah say yourself so
the item one is to consider the request
from
malden assistant advice at appendix one
uh can we have a sense that we have done
that agreed
agreed yes yes item
two is to confirm that they wish to
increase
funding to mold and cities advice from
73
500 to 75 000
for the year 21 to 22.
can we have a ascent or do we wish for a
vote on this item
german can i have clarity because yes
thank you we have
actually um discussed it but we haven't
agreed it because we've still got
information to come back and
councillor white when she started
actually speaking originally asked if it
could
be deferred now i need to actually ask
mr holmes or whoever
if we can at this stage to defer it
otherwise we're going to be making a
decision
and then going back on it which we all
know we can't do i think
yeah before you go to mr holmes what i
would like to say
is item two is that we are for the year
21
22 agreeing to continue funding
to give that security to the citizens
advice bureau
and we are um increasing their funding
from 73
500 to 75 000. so that's a separate item
to then looking at future years
so yeah my view is yeah we need to trade
take take that as a separate issue mr
holmes
i i think that's i think that's correct
chairman i think this will give the
um security for cab for the the next
year um
if you wish to see that increase uh come
up from 73 500 this is the opportunity
to do that
but i would say this recommendation
still goes forward uh to the next
committee and then to council so there's
still more couple more steps yeah
yeah so can i have a cent for
item two agree
agreed agreed okay
and then i i would like to recorded that
i don't agree that because we have no
financial figures to base this on it's
not because i don't want to support the
cb
it's because we don't have any financial
records to do pace this
to base the decision on and say it's not
that i don't want to do it
i don't feel comfortable with taxpayers
money when i've seen no accounts
okay as so as we do not have a cent we
will have to have a recorded vote
on this item so miss bird could you do a
recorded vote please
uh yes chairman of course um members if
you could just indicate when i call your
name
if you're for against or abstaining
sorry can i just be clear what we're
voting on we're voting on little two
which is to confirm that they wish to
increase funding to modern citizens
advice
from 73 500 to 75
000 for the year 2021 to 22.
that is at the count that we recommend
that they have correct
correct tara
thank you chairman and starting with mrs
china please
lagging
swain or
you counsel mrs thompson or
councillor miss white
against but only because we do not have
any accuracy
thank you councillor white thank you
very much so chairman the results of
that are nine
four one against and one abstention
thank you very much
thank you miss bird uh so item three is
to consider funding for 22
22 cut onwards as i said about 2022
onwards as part of a report on the
future procurement brought back to
strategy resources
in spring 2021 so
uh and and we are now suggesting that
the uh the the information is presented
to the working group
and if necessary if there is not an
alternative
uh provider that we bring that further
forward is that correct mr holmes
yes i think yes chairman i think perhaps
you if you wanted to be a little bit um
uh clearer on a little three you could
uh say as soon as possible
and on the spring 2021 and we will
obviously endeavor to do that
correct thank you so if we change that
to
as soon as feasibly possible that this
is brought item is brought back to
the strategic resources committee
rather than spring 22 can you make that
amendment tara please
yes of course chairman thank you again
can we
do we need a recorded vote or do are we
happy for a cent on the item
agree that agreed agreed
thank you agreed thank you thank you
members
uh item 13 any other items of business
that the chairman
of the committee decides are urgent and
there are none
which brings us on to item 14 exclusion
of the republican press uh
as chairman to move that under section
108
sorry this council channel oh sorry get
my mobile out of the way
sorry chairman um i did declare an
interest earlier
and just to you know reiterate that i'm
going because there's
within the report a body mentioned that
i am related to if you like so
um i don't mean a body unrelated so it's
an organization that i'm
related to and it's named in the report
so i feel it much better as i've never
been involved any
discussions about any matter to do with
what might the report might be alluding
to
um i'm leaving now chairman i'm going to
if you give me time to get out
yes of course councillor china thank you
very much councillor thompson you wanted
to make a suggestion
oh thank you chairman um yes it was only
because this
business of declaring on items that are
private and confidential this all be
complicated so
um sometimes it can be helpful if the
member just states at the beginning of
the meeting that you know they have an
interest
yeah and we wait until we get into the
private session before they actually
tell us
what it is and then we then we don't
have to talk all around it
i think and i do know what counselor
chan is talking about and i'm not
at all disagreeing with what she's
saying but you know if she was still
here at the very beginning of the next
item she'd be able to tell us
what she really meant as indeed what
i think she's trying to be helpful
so i'm absolutely certain she was trying
to be helpful it's just a thought if if
anyone thinks it really matters
um that they tell us what it really is
about then they can always wait until we
get into that part of the meeting
thank you councillor thompson for that
wonderful suggestion very helpful
so item 14 that under section 100a
brackets 4 of the local government at
1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the like for the following item of
business on the grounds that it
involves the likely disclosure of exempt
information
as defined in paris one and two of part
one
of the schedule 12a to the act and that
this satisfies the public
interest test
you